et on poursuit avec vous sébastien en
première journée de campagne c'est très
important de faire bonne impression
lc réussi pour françois legault tout
d'abord celui des moments importants
dans une compagnie terra la première
journée les débats la dernière semaine
aussi lorsque les parties essaient de
faire en cette première journée c'est
d'imposer un enjeu l'enjeu qui leur
apparaît le plus important dont françois
legault l'a bien joué parce que les
sondages disent que les québécois lui
font confiance et il a
posé une question qui est le meilleur
pour et le pot se décline de plusieurs
façons pour la création combattre
l'inflation pour le réseau de la santé
pour l'identité québécoise et c'est
probablement fait dire que c'était ça
pouvait marquer les esprits cette
question qu'il pose aux québécois
aujourd'hui donc il n'a pas dit il se
positionne mais ils n'attaquent pas de
front ses adversaires probables on s'est
fait dire c'est pas bon d'attaquer de
front ses adversaires ça paraît mal mais
il le fait tellement pas d'attaquer ses
adversaires de francs qu'il ose même pas
nommé le nom de dominique anglade la
chef du parti libéral qui devient la
madame et ça c'est un faux pas dans ceux
première journée de campagne doit donc
il a bien c'est qu'on suit je pense la
question qu'il faut qu'ils posent aux
québécois mais en même temps ça nous
rappelle que probablement le pire ennemi
de françois legault c'est françois
legault en campagne électorale qu'il ait
jamais loin d'une cure de bananes qu'il
jette lui même sur son nom maintenant le
défi pour les partis d'opposition c'est
arrivé de se présenter comme une option
de rechange à la caq donc qui s'en est
sorti devenu aujourd'hui allons-y parle
il est parti le parti libéral dominique
anglade revient à l'adn de son parti
c'est à dire en mettant de l'avant
l'économie mais en même temps et la voix
de même les québécois la connaissent mal
donc il ya une recherche d'identité du
parti bien est-ce que en 35 36 jours et
va avoir le temps de définir cette
identité c'est un gros défi le fait de
commencer sa campagne tout seul devant
son hôte car cinq candidats derrière
elle aussi c'est peut-être parce qu'il
ya de plus mobilisateur al'inverse
québec solidaire a mobilisé c'est six
candidats 75 qui étaient présents dans
la région de sherbrooke
mais la démonstration que québec
solidaire doit faire c'est que son
programme est crédible en particulier
pour la réduction des gaz à effet de
serre c'est le parti le plus ambitieux
sur ce plan là qu'est ce que ça va
vouloir dire dans nos vies à une
démonstration à faire le parti québécois
se replie dans ses convictions dans ses
principes dans la fondation du parti en
parlant de souveraineté de langue
française vous allez me reste plus grand
chose d'autre pour le parti québécois en
ce moment qu'ils essaient de sauver les
meubles avant de construire en 1re 2e
étage bâti sur sa fondation et quant au
parti conservateur c'est intéressant
d'entendre éric duhaime parler de
l'inflation parce que lui il faut qu'il
fasse la démonstration que son parti
c'est autre chose que des frustrés des
mesures sanitaires et qu'il a une
plateforme électorale qui se tient donc
démonstration de crédibilité pour
monsieur duhaime à faire encore merci
beaucoup et sébastien ont leurs
problèmes ce que vise à part merci à
vous aussi sans voix